And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Now the Scoutmaster Podcast Top 10..
It's not a copyrighted feature of the podcast, but you know.
Here's the Top 10 signs. you've probably listened to the podcast a little too much.
That's right.
Top 10 signs you've listened a little too much.
Number 10.
Secretly, Brick Mason is your hero.
Number 9.
The happy wanderer is the ringtone on your cell phone.
Number 8.
People tell you that you're too tense and it makes you giggle a little bit.
You gotta think about that one.
Number 7.
You've encouraged your senior patrol leader to listen to the podcast.
Number 6.
You own a Kuiper Pass and you've tried to use it at your camp trading post.
Number 5.
You own at least one of the books recommended on the podcast.
Number 4.
You've quoted the podcast and given the link out to Assistant Scoutmaster's troop, community
members and or roundtable attendees.
Number 3.
All the podcasts are on your smartphone for quick and easy access.
Number 2.
You've retold the jokes you've heard on the podcast around a campfire.
And the number one sign that you've probably listened to too many podcasts:
You've listened to the first 99 podcasts and you're still listening.
This is podcast number 100..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
That was the top 10, was from good buddy of the podcast, Great Scouter, Bill McFarlane.
Thank you, Bill,
And thank you for your for your best wishes here at podcast number 100 and for your contribution.
Did I mention that this is podcast number 100?
Yeah, that's right.
How about that? huh,
I didn't know whether or not we were going to make it a few times, but hey, people keep
listening, people keep getting involved and that's going to be the subject of the podcast.
is your feedback and your involvement?
Nothing real serious this time around, because you know let's have a little fun,
Because did I mention that this is podcast number 100?
That's right,
We got the marching band and everything.
So let's listen for a moment as they march by.
Thank you, gentlemen,
Thank you,
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it,
You too.
Well, now let's get down to business here.
Well, Hansman wrote in this past week.
He said: I truly enjoy reading the blog, both the content and the comments,
And the comments are a real important part of the blog.
We're going to talk a little bit about that after a bit.
Both the content and the comments help inspire me on my scouting journey.
Well, thanks.
Well. Jamie Humphries wrote in. he said this:
Hey, Clark, again, thanks for all the words of wisdom you put out every week.
Funny thing happened the other day.
I was playing your podcast on the two hour drive to one of our council camps.
My son was along with me.
He just crossed over from Weeblows and he was riding in the backseat
And I thought he was asleep.
But he started discussing your podcast with me when we got home.
He downloaded all the episodes so he could listen to them himself.
I just thought you might want to know that scouts as well as
scouts get a lot out of your material.
Thank you so much, Jamie.
Jamie's a brand new scout master in troop 4277 in Flugerville, Texas.
That's where we hear from him.
A few people have called in to send their best wishes on the 100th podcast.
Here's a familiar name.
This is Frank Maynard of Bob White Blather, here to congratulate Clark Green
on the 100th episode of the Scout Master Podcast.
Thanks for all your help and inspiration.
Well, Frank, thank you so much and thanks for getting in touch.
You know Frank's a troop committee chair and he has a great blog called
Bob White Blather
And you need to go and check it out because it gives you a really great
practical perspective of scouting from that committee position
And I found a lot of useful things on there.
Thanks again, Frank.
We also heard from another friend,
Clark. hello,
This is John Marsh from Tacumcy, Tac 607..
Clark, I wanted to congratulate you on your 100th episode.
I've been listening since about episode 30 or so and come to really appreciate
your opinion about things and got a lot of benefit from your show.
Anyway, congratulations.
Thanks a lot, Clark.
Take care
Well. thank you, John.
Thanks for being in touch.
John also left a question that I'm going to answer in a future podcast
about the job of chartered organization representative.
So I started the Scout Master blog in 2005 and we started the podcast
two years ago,
And the responses that I receive indicate that people find it helpful
And I enjoy hearing from a lot of folks every week
And if you're already one of them, thank you.
If you're not, you know, feel free to get in touch.
I have kind of a basic idea that several hundred people listen or read
regularly,
But tracking numbers like that is a really fuzzy and exact science.
The only way to know that people are actually out there is to hear from
them directly, either through an email or a voicemail or, you know,
through one of the social media networks
And there's some really smart people,
People that are smarter than me- that read the blog and leave
comments as well.
It would be remiss of me not to mention Larry Geiger and Tom
Gillard and Walter Underwood.
They always added something to the conversation- very experienced
scouters, very smart guys,
And I invited them to join me on the podcast for the last several
months as a member of a Scoutmasters panel,
And I'll tell you right now that podcast 101 will feature a
Scoutmasters panel discussion
And I'm finding those a lot of fun and I'm finding them pretty
useful.
You can also email-
Got a lot of emails in the space of a week, but I'm always
happy to read them and respond to them-
And you can also subscribe to all the posts that I put up on the
blog and you would get notified every time this podcast comes
out.
You can subscribe on the blog via email at scoutmasterscgcom
and you'll get an email notification anytime something
new shows up there on the blog.
This continues to be a very gratifying experience because
people get in touch, because I know that people listen and I
know- and they tell me- that they get something out of it-
What really got me writing the blog and what got me doing the
podcast was the idea that scouting is a pretty universal
concept and that it works really, really well.
In the case of what I'm doing, it helps a lot of young men
through a potentially difficult period of time in their
lives.
It helps them kind of find their feet, gives them a way
to express their interest and energy in a very positive
manner.
So scouting has been an effective, meaningful movement to
many, many, many of us over the past a little more
than a century now,
And while the World Wide Web certainly isn't in its
infancy- it's still developing-
We're still learning how to use these channels of
communication and how to work together to make them
effective in informing the work that we do as
scout leaders.
Hopefully, this podcast is a small part of that effort
in moving things forward.
The one thing that I think you can draw from any of
the messages that you hear here and any of the
advice that you get is that we are all in this
together.
It really doesn't matter where we are- not just in
the United States but in the world, because I've
had the pleasure of talking to several people
outside of the United States and you've heard a
couple of the interviews that I've recorded with
people in Tunisia and South Africa, places
that are going to be culturally very different,
But scouting is designed to adapt to different
cultures and different ways of life and to
address just some basic things about us as human
beings,
And that is why it works and it will continue to
work so long as we apply it right.
And no matter where in the world you go, you're
going to find that you experience the same
triumphs, the same challenges, the same
difficulties, the same achievements that all
of your fellow scouts do all over the world.
It's really quite amazing.
So there are these common things that, once we
begin to see and understand them, we can apply
to the scouting movement to do a little bit of
good in the world and to create some good human
beings.
And that's what it's all about.
And so long as we can serve that end, we'll
keep on with the podcast and the blog and all
of that stuff.
So my heartfelt thanks in you're making this
effort worthwhile.
Spread the word, let people know and get
people involved in the conversation.
That's what really makes it work.
That's what really makes this happen.
I want to play a story that I recorded some
time ago.
I think I may have gotten it into one of
the earlier podcasts, but it's one of my
favorite stories from summer camp.
That's how we're going to close the
Scoutmaster podcast number 100..
And again, my thanks to you
And you'll hear more about how to get in
touch after we're done.
Favored, All-Time Boys Scout.
Favored All-Time Boys Scout.
You are always on the beat boy, beat boy. yeah, You are always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang it in the street boy, street boy. We will dance into the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
You're my favorite all-time boy scout. You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Hi, I'm Kevin Cowan and I'm listening to Scoutmaster iPod.
What is it called again,
Hi, I'm Kevin Cowan, the happy camper, and you're listening to the Scoutmaster podcast.
Ah, beautiful, beautiful.
Our patrols keep a patrol log and it's summer camp.
It's especially useful because it kind of gives them a report on the day
that they can bring to the senior patrol leader at our evening patrol leader's council meeting.
So here we are, we're sitting around at night of a, you know, a sultry summer camp day
and the bugs are chirping and carrying on.
and you know, I've got this one very young new patrol leader.
He's kind of acting like you know a new employee would act in a board meeting or something like that,
being very deferential and kind of quiet.
You know, when it came his turn to talk about what was in his patrol log for the day,
he mentioned that one of the boys in the patrol was somewhat concerned about the snake
that was living under his tent platform.
That's what he said.
Now you gotta understand where we go camping. there's, you know, snakes.
There's garter snakes, there's a very rare roughneck green snake,
There's rat snakes, there's several different kinds of snake,
But most importantly there's one that we have to pay particular attention to
and that's a copperhead.
If you're not familiar with copperheads, copperheads are poisonous.
They're not going to out now kill you, but it's certainly unpleasant to be bitten by one.
So as the patrol leader sat there and he said rather quietly:
Yeah, you know, Alex is a little concerned about the snake that lives under his tent,
It kind of caught my attention.
After the patrol leader's council meeting I grabbed one of my assistant scoutmasters
and I said: let's go look at the snake that's living under Alex's tent.
It might be a good idea.
And so anyway is, you know, we're sleeping on tent platforms.
There are wooden platforms, that tents are set on the top
and the scouts are headed off to the shower house
before they hit the hay for the evening.
and I thought you know, we'll just go down very quietly,
We'll take a look at this and see exactly what's going on.
So here we are, we're down on our hands and knees
kind of looking around underneath the tent platform
and there he is, it's a snake.
And guess what kind of snake it is?
Can you guess?
Huh,
Oh yeah, yeah, it's a little. it's a little copperhead.
You know these, I've dealt with these guys before
and they're you want to treat them with respect and things.
So I asked one of the fellas who is on the camp staff,
who was down in the site with us. it's one of our scouts.
I said you know, go on up, find the nature director,
tell them we got a snake
and tell them to bring the snake stick and stuff down there.
You know they've got a, you know we wait about 10 or 15 minutes
and the nature director comes running breathlessly into the campsite
and in rather a louder voice than I would have hoped,
he talks about the copperhead
and we've got to capture this copperhead
and I'm like, yeah, well, let's, we might be able to do this
without causing a whole lot of craziness
and let's just keep it quiet. oh, oh, yeah, okay.
So we begin trying to kind of, you know,
reach under the platform and get the snake.
and of course the snake is not very interested in this.
the snake would rather stay where he's at,
he's comfortable. he's got a couple of scouts right there,
should he need to bite them, poison them for any reason.
so he's really got a pretty good crib right there
and he's not very interested in moving.
one thing leads to another right,
and finally there's, you know, five adults and scouts
and 10 flashlights and there's a lot of hollering.
so our quiet little snake extraction turns into, you know,
a major operation
and we've completely disassembled the tent platform
to get at this snake
and finally get it in the snake stick
after a whole lot of excitement.
and so me and the nature director
walk on down the trail to a remote part of camp
to release the snake and just, you know, let him be,
he'll be out there where he won't bother anybody.
and so I thought, you know, great end of story.
the boys won't be concerned about this copperhead.
of course they'll be concerned that there is a copperhead now
under every tent platform,
because we didn't manage to do it very quietly
but we all headed off to bed
and I had kind of figured that we were done.
but we weren't.
no, of course we weren't.
you know, one of the great things about being in camp with the scouts
is that any little piece of news travels very quickly
in camp. we call it the moccasin telegraph.
pretty soon the whole camp knows
and then the story gets embroidered and embellished.
so here we are, we're walking back from lunch the next day.
I get back to the campsite
and one of my assistant leaders catches up with me
and he says yeah, he says
there's quite a story about the snake last night.
and I say really.
he says yeah, well, this is the story right now,
because as he was walking back from lunch
he heard scouts from another troop discussing this.
so the story was that there was this huge copperhead
coiled up on the bed-
not under the platform but on the bed
of one of the young scouts in our troop-
and it was attacking them
and the scoutmaster had to kill it with an axe
and then had apparently skin that made a hatband
to be sporting at that night's retreat ceremony.
so you know, that's the way the moccasin telegraph works, isn't it?
and it has tempted me before to create some stories,
but I've managed to resist the temptation.
I'll tell them to you here.
This is Cliff Jacobson
and you're listening to the Scoutmaster podcast
with Clark Green.
Well, since this is the 100th podcast,
I want to especially thank you for having found it
and listened.
I've had a lot of fun choosing music for the podcast
and I've got to say,
even though I've actually
I've actually had complaints about the music
that you hear playing right now,
this is 101 strings
and this is Taps for the Fallen Brave,
and I always close the podcast with Taps
of one version or another
because you know, Taps- that's the last bugle hall
we hear at night before we head off to bed at camp,
and you know, I just thought it was a fun way to close off the podcast.
and the 101 strings.
if you're younger than me-
significantly younger than me-
you probably don't know a whole lot about the 101 strings
unless you had a parent with similar musical tastes,
and my condolences if you did.
oh, I just love it
and I know a couple other people really like it too,
so it'll stay a staple of the podcast.
we'll change it out with a few other versions of Taps every once in a while.
here's how to stay in touch.
first of all, you can email me,
and the email address is
scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
you can read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe there to receive updates by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or a review or a rating.
you can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
you can get details of that at Stitchercom.
you can also call and leave a voicemail, comment
or question at 4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2.
that's what the fellows did earlier.
when you heard them on the podcast, they called that number.
you can also experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
in the podcast through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
you can tweet us at scoutmastercg on Twitter.
we have four: admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg circle.
search for scoutmastercg on Google Plus:
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast.
they're not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
and boy are they happy about that.
no, they're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America. either
it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
well before we go, as always, we're going to hear
from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
now, this time, we're going to hear from our founder
as interpreted by voiceover artist Britt Helms.
Britt's a listener and a great scouter,
and he sent me this recording
of his best take of Baden-Powell
to take us out on podcast number 100.
well, thank you, Sir Robert.
anything else,
good luck to you and good campus.
thank you very much, Sir.
until next time, everybody.
thanks again
you.